[Musica]
buonasera come avvicinare la gente ai
musei come avvicinare la gente ai musei
dopo un anno e mezzo di totale
inaccessibilità dei musei con poche
eccezioni ma in realtà come avvicinare
la gente ai musei dopo anni e decenni in
cui di musei erano comunque
inaccessibili per molti socialmente
perché i musei erano concepiti come
manuali di storia dell'arte manuali in
cui si poteva entrare come si sfoglia un
libro
effettivamente per avere un altro
approccio bisogna iniziare con l'atto
stesso l'arte è fortissimo e quando non
è fortissimo allora bisogna scegliere
altre opere feste quindi le opere d'arte
vanno messo in scena come se fosse una
scena teatrale o del cinema senza
esagerare
dipende sempre dall arte che si
interpreta con i spazi vengono messo in
una relazione l'uno con altro vangogh
quindi bisogna evitare un ordine
catalografico paratattico e invece
creare cercare di creare un ordine
sintattico un ordine che affidamenti
ispira le persone a un'esperienza
artistica e non solo e non soltanto gli
sottopone a un esame un esame vero
un esame che la gente confrontati con
questi capolavori assoluti si sente di
dover affrontare ad esempio creare dei
dialoghi tra la famosa medusa del
caravaggio e un'altra medusa
che per molti secoli era molto più
famosa degli uffizi perché era un opera
erroneamente attribuito a leonardo da
vinci poi si è capito che invece di un
pittore olandese del seicento e da quel
momento in poi era addirittura in
depositi troveremo anche anni questo
accostamento ispira la gente a vedere
con i propri occhi e magari scoprire
qualcosa che stories lato prima non
hanno visto mettere queste opere in un
spazio architettonico suggestivo che può
con il color rosso evocare una camera da
letto di un principe del seicento che
sembra quasi velluto oppure anche
alludere al rosso del sangue che appunto
troviamo raffigurato in queste immagini
di medusa oppure ricordarsi attraverso
la scelta di uno scudo di bronzo che
nella storia dei medici
questo quadro era esposto nella armeria
e non nella pinacoteca è importantissimo
anche l'interpretazione che interi
quotatissima che l'interpretazione è
l'invito parte delle opere d'arte stesse
che le opere d'arte non hanno bisogno di
ulteriori ulteriore segnaletiche e che
le didascalie che vengono aggiunte non
siano scritti in gergo di storia
dell'arte ma che siano stampati in
caratteri
accessibili anche per i dislessici ma
che in semplici frasi al massimo delle
informazioni venga condensata qui
abbiamo alcune pale del della
controriforma che si vedono proprio in
un allestimento che suggerisce il loro
contesto originale cioè un contesto
religioso senza però ricostruirlo in
maniera storici sta solo come allusione
e che fa vedere che proprio l'arte che
spesso viene snobbata perché considerato
troppo didascalica in realtà è molto
molto molto ricca e molto diversa anche
tra di loro c'è accostando otto opere di
quel periodo
in una sala per offrire una esperienza
oppure appunto la camera da letto
veneziana che si può alludere un
allestimento che unisce tre delle più
grandi bellezze del cinquecento che
furono ammirati e che ai quali ora si
può per la prima volta avvicinare grazie
una nuova tecnologia non digitale ma una
tecnologia del vetro con una bassissima
infrangendo i vetri super trasparenti si
potrebbe dire ogni mattina infatti ci
sono sempre le impronte nasali che
bisogna
pulire perché fino a pochi millimetri
che ci si può avvicinare letteralmente
entrare nel quadro con tutti i suoi
particolari il allestimento di è logico
può anche mettere in parallelo è in
contrasto due artisti con le loro
caratteristiche e diversita come il
rosso fiorentino e il pontormo due
artisti che già il vasari aveva messo in
parallelo che però grazie a un
accostamento di due quadri con figure
nude invitano e stimolano i visitatori
di capire per sé cosa sono le
caratteristiche di ciascuna di queste
opere oppure non solo due artisti ma
anche due scuole due regioni artistiche
come la toscana e il lazio roma i
seguaci di michelangelo e come ognuno di
loro in maniere diverse prende modelli
prende invenzioni del buonarroti e li
sviluppa ognuno per sé in un'altra
maniera alcuno qualcuno come una cola
altri in maniera molto molto originale
trasformando il modello in qualcosa di
nuovo e in specie le gli artisti
veneziani in viaggio a roma che poi
aggiungono e loro senso del colorismo e
dello sfumato
si possono anche a costare due periodi
storici diversi spesso è oramai una
prassi comune di accostare opere antiche
e classiche con arte contemporanea anche
noi lo facciamo senz'altro però anche
all'interno di
una suite di sale dedicata al
rinascimento al barocco di avere una
sala dedicata al rilievo classico greco
e soprattutto romano senza studiare
molto molti testi si capisce solo
guardando l'importanza della scultura
tridimensionale per la composizione
delle opere la composizione pittorica
del rinascimento al di là della
interpretazione delle opere d'arte
basato sulla vestimento sulla scelta
delle opere è però fondamentale
l'elemento umano ogni visita in un museo
è un'esperienza sociale anche chi viene
in un museo da solo si trova sempre con
altre persone almeno con le guardie ma
in realtà in genere con molte altre
persone ma la maggior parte delle
persone viene con d'amici famiglia e
quindi è sempre una un dialogo e che
nasce dall'arte e questo è
importantissimo anche i social media
hanno la funzione in questo senso e
quindi una maniera per poter avvicinare
persone che prima non che prima erano
lontani da questa istituzione è quello
di invitare persone che sono invece
molto vicino a loro
al museo la non so se qualcuno conosce
la ragazza che è qui al centro del
milanese si chiama martina socrate che è
venuta per una nostra diretta
non so se qualcuno conosce questa
ragazza di cremona che anche venuta da
noi sa che qui si vede ancora po meglio
quindi gente che normalmente non era
associato
per niente con il mondo dell'arte di
usarlo come mediatore con per i musei e
poi soprattutto di avere persone non
solo i curatori per esempio anche i
tecnici le guardie appunto tutte
professionalità diverse a spiegare le
singole opere d'arte ha un altissimo
livello perché ovviamente si possono
anche preparare molti sono
preparatissimi perché lavoro nel museo
da molto molto da molto da tanto tempo e
alcuni giardinieri biologi sono riuscito
finalmente a tenere l'attenzione per più
di un'ora ed effetti il pubblico e avere
un pubblico sempre crescente tempo che
noi non abbiamo tuttavia un ultimo
elemento è questo di portare un'altra
arte dentro al museo come ad esempio la
musica così veramente si uniscono le
varie arti che si uniscono arte di varie
culture si uniscono arte anche di vari
secoli e questo è sempre produttivo
perché l'idea non è quella che tutti i
settori musei poi diventino storici
l'arte ma è proprio quella che l'arte da
qualcosa anche di emotivo per la propria
vita e solo così a un vero senso grazie
[Applauso]